ukraine wir wissen ganz genau
was er verteidigen bewegender moment im
deutschen fernsehen die dolmetscherin
der ansprache des ukrainischen
präsidenten kämpft während der
übersetzung mit den tränen was so ihr
verteidigen
die tränen die wir nur hören aber nicht
sehen bewegen die sozialen medien der
ausschnitt von welt.tv wird tausendfach
geteilt während die dolmetscherin
simultan übersetzt kann sie ihre gefühle
nicht mehr kontrollieren ihr schluchzen
ist deutlich zu hören
professionell entschuldigt sich die
übersetzerin für ihren gefühlsausbruch
doch genau dafür wird sie jetzt gefeiert
sie haben durch ihre emotionen mehr
übersetzt als sie jemals hätten sagen
können
eine japanische kollegin der frau
schreibt ich bin auch
konferenzdolmetscher es muss sehr schwer
für sie gewesen sein unter diesen
umständen ruhig zu bleiben ich bewundere
ihre auf richtige einstellung zu ihrer
arbeit auf twitter meldet sich die
dolmetscherin selbst zu wort sie habe an
dem tag zehn stunden lang für das
deutsche fernsehen friedensgespräche
gedolmetscht doch bei den letzten worten
ihres präsidenten sei sie in tränen
ausgebrochen
ich liebe euch alle meine mit ukraine
beschließt sie den freed und hat durch
ihre emotionale übersetzung schon jetzt
einen platz in den herzen der menschen
sicher was so er verteidigen
[Musik]